Các bình xí iren thắp sát lộ bộ lên 2 tầu hàng với cáu buộc hóa đậu trái phép ở LBN Hó Mũs.
Video zor vệ bình cách mạng hồi giáo iren cộng bố cho thấy lực lượng này dùng xung cau tắc tiếp cạnh
rồi chào lên tầu bằng thang dây.
Theo Reuters, Tau bị chạc la Francesca được cho là của công ty vận tải để chung hại.
Và e-fakt mirodas trên tầu chào cơ Libertaria, cả hai đang tìm cách dở vì quà e-o hóa mũs ngoài khởi oman ngày
thằng từ, Iran cáu buộc các phương kiện này hoạt động không phép nhiều lần bí phạm quy định tại LBN.
Các tầu này có bị cáu buộc làm sai lệ kể thống bốc trợ điều hướng và đe dọa an ninh hàng hại,
nhằm biệt vượt qua e-o hóa mũs.
Ví vệ bình hành tầu e-famino das sau đó xanh nhận, còn tầu đã bị lực lượng Iran lên khiểm sát,
đồng thời cho biết tủy trụ đoàn an toàn.
Iran đã áp dại hai tầu vào lãnh hại để khiểm tra.
Bù việc diễn ra khi Iran tiếp tục sít khiểm sát el hòa mũs, còn Mỹ vẫn duy chỉ phong tỏ hành hại,
đối với hảm đập thương bại liên quan các càng Iran.
Nhà chẳng nói, việc Iran chẳng hai tầu này không bị coi là bị phạm ngừng bán,
vì đây không phải tổ bi, hai y sửa n.